so here you are
two little girls your mom is gone
haven't been killed by gun violence
you gotta raise these two little girls
on your own how did you
[Music]
what's up everybody my name is pastor
corey brooks and you got it i'm still
here can you believe it on this rooftop
living in this tent behind me for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
i'm bringing awareness of the gun
violence that we deal with in chicago
every single day but i'm also trying to
raise as much money as possible to build
a community center in a much needed
neighborhood this neighborhood that we
call o block o
i say is for opportunity the gang say is
for a young man who was shot and killed
named od perry but we're turning this
into a place of opportunity because
that's what we need in our neighborhood
and today i am like super super excited
to have with me a young sister
who if there's anyone epitomizes
making it through heartaches and
hardships and struggle
it's the queen of wilkes sequina thank
you for coming to our rooftop revelation
thank you for having me listen i want to
jump right in
um i know your story
and it's amazing first of all
and but i want our listeners to hear
because i need them to understand
the difficulties and the trials that
some young girls go through not just our
boys but our girls when it comes to gun
violence can you tell us
how did you end up
in
a group home
oh well my mom was murdered by her
boyfriend
living with family
um
i was going down the wrong path a little
bit i wound up pregnant
at 15 had my daughter at 16 and i ended
right back up in the group homes again
and then you had your then you had
another daughter what a 21. so 21. so
here you are
two little girls your mom is gone
haven't been killed by gun violence
you got to raise these two little girls
on your own how did you
get through that how did you
navigate through that what happened
yeah i don't know i guess
seeing things going through things and
seeing things and
different paths that people take as far
as my family is concerned
um friends and things like that um i
just knew i didn't want that to be me or
i didn't want my daughters um to grow up
and just have a peeled out mother or you
know like because a lot of these young
women they lose their way and they don't
know how to be a mother they don't know
how to be a parent so they just give
their kids away and i didn't want to be
that parent because i kind of struggled
like that growing up as well you know
being a young girl because you could
have easily made an excuse
and said well my mom was in this
situation and this happened and i had
baby and you could have made all kinds
of excuses right exactly but you didn't
no and matter of fact
you have done so well that you went to
school and now you're what are you doing
right now um i was a cna for seven years
i'm actually a patient care technician
um
i kind of basically just shifted my way
into the security field uh back in 2018
i do armed and unarmed security i now
work at a children's hospital as
security officer um but i
really inspired i i flipped because i
aspire to be about these songs hold on
hold on hold on
you grew up on all that stuff
and on this outside of chicago and you
want to be the police yeah
why do you want to be a police officer
um because i feel like you you're not
gonna know how to relate to nobody out
here
unless you actually been out here in
these streets and you really walk these
streets you really went through what's
going on out here you've got to relate
you have to so have you taken the test
yet yes twice right we believe you're
gonna pass it right yes all right so
look i love you
i believe in you
you
epitomize what we're trying to do with
the sisters in our neighborhood
just because you make a mistake or just
because some stuff happened to you in
your past
you can still be successful you can
still make it and you can achieve all
your dreams and i believe you're going
to be
one of the best police officers that
we've had in our neighborhood in a long
time
all right thank you thank you all right
listen it's been great as always shouts
out to my fox family for giving me this
platform to talk about issues and
solutions and all the things that we're
concerned about on the south side of
chicago things that hopefully will make
us better i'll see you tomorrow and
until then
peace
[Music]
you